Clifton when you first started acting
and booking roles what was your vision
for your acting career vision for my
acting career gosh you know I think when
you're younger I don't know I don't know
that we always know the real reasons
where we get into a business um
sometimes it's in hindsight that you
realize oh these were the steps that led
me up to this I don't know I don't know
that I had one I I know I wanted to do
roles that mattered and I wanted to
represent communities of people that
didn't have voices I knew that going in
just kind of interesting insight to have
it as a young man I was 17 when you grew
up around the business didn't you didn't
your grandfather a fourth generation
entertainer so my grandfather my great
grandfather my great grandmother
so my grandfather was a contract player
for John Wayne did a lot of the westerns
so when you told your family that you
wanted to know sort of being an
entertainer did they say well you know
there's also a downside to it was it
were they always positive about it or
where the heart my father was the only
positive voice he was the only you can
do it that I got like that my mother was
not for my career many friends weren't
it's a tough business you know but my
grandpa was like no you can do it I know
you can do it I just need to hear it
Denis Tony believed in me now is the one
voice did you do a lot of invitations
because you have such a chameleon like
style you can be so many different
people did you imitate a lot of people I
did that's really into you absolutely I
gotten a lot of trouble in high school
because of it yeah I got laughs I did I
got to me because grandpa was you think
it would be like Rio Bravo with Dean
Martin and Walter Brennan and all these
unique different voices so it was it was
just fun to
we started tap dancing over seven so you
know sometimes just to pass the time as
a kid that do voices me my cousin you
know sometimes I'm you hate it when
you're tap-dancing to seven you just
don't like it today I love it
well you consider as your first success
as an actor first success guy you know I
think ah I think there's a danger in
saying a first success because I think
life is just a series of successes and
failures so even in this business I mean
you know success to me is this doing the
job that I got to do in that room you
know whether I get the role or not but
the fact that I I'm able to pull off a
performance and give a performance cuz I
like to give a performance when I
audition instead of auditioning you know
I kind of like to do a lot of the prep
work prior like some of the heavier prep
work that most actors might reserve for
after they get the kid if I have the
time I'll I'll tell deeply into it just
that's part of the fun you know if you
want to do a good job but in regards to
making a living gosh you know
you'reyou're it's that struggle you're
juggling jobs you're juggling regular
jobs that let you go to auditions on top
of auditioning you know so it's like
there's a struggle in that and there's a
success in that as well so I'd seen
regards to like benchmarks in my career
like you know your first gig that you
get you get to be sag you get your sag
card like well I got my sag card
that was my first commercial so that
that was that was fun and then you look
at a film like maybe one eighty seven
which was probably one of the greater
challenges in my early career you know
there's so much to learn a mentorship I
got from Sam Jackson was just you know
it kind of set the pace for me in a lot
of different ways and the ways that he
acted and how he prepped even deeper and
harder longer I was
like oh my god I got to do this so I
want to I want to be that good watch and
say I'm doing his thing and it's just
like my god so he set the bar pretty
high for me that was fun but that was I
think my first really big role and then
to be challenged by somebody of Sam's
caliber and to rise up to that occasion
you know that that was uh that was fine
and I know with a lot of things in this
town you can go to one level and then
you think oh it's just gonna keep being
like this upward staircase and you kind
of sometimes realize you're back to
square one for sure how do you in any
and definitely avoid square one yes so
much so um how do you deal with that
square one point because you know we
just love it you do you have to do you
have to UM you got a little process if
you love the process and you can I think
be okay for the most part and the square
of the square one thing it's uh you know
you're constantly and yes it's always a
struggle I think you know there's
there's different forms the challenges
reinvent themselves the obstacles and at
you try to try to develop the foresight
to be able to see those things come in
but um when I get back to square one
it's it's you know you embrace it and
then you work diligently and extra hard
to you know to get ahead you know in
your craft and auditions or whatever it
is you're doing writing directing so
who's your character Nathan and cooking
somebody
um Nathan's Nathan's a troubled soul
who's been dealing with his past and
he's as a result he's struggling with
atonement he wants to atone I don't
think he just he just doesn't know how
yeah it's a it's interesting question do
you think people can change sorry to
jump in no please do you think people
really can change I do people can I do
believe that people can change but I
also I mean you got to go past square
one you got to get knocked down and be
humbled
you know like truly truly your souls got
to be humbled and I think only then will
real change happen you know I don't
think it's just amazing these times as
we look at our society you know there's
so many I find it troubling that people
have to get knocked down just to have
any sense of empathy or compassion or
you know for others it's like why do you
have to be down and out to care about
people you and I mean so you know
Nathan's already down and out and I
think he probably he's been down and out
for quite some time so that beats you
down when you don't address an issue you
know whether it's a physical ailment an
emotional mental things like that you
know they're gonna turn into something
else that's not positive and they'll
continue to grow and you continue to
attempt to manage it as best as you can
to survive so you know you don't ever
really find out what Nathan used to do
but I try to reverse-engineer so much
stuff and you know he still lives in a
you know in a trailer and a band
yeah so he's he's surviving barely you
might be protecting himself - yeah could
be there's no there's a lot of different
things yeah but certainly um you know I
want it to be able to demonstrate that
darkness it's in all of us and it's up
to us to act on it and I wanted to be
able to show that he's still quite
capable of being that bad person it's
really about him beating control of his
emotions and a desire to really change
you know so I don't I don't know I think
you know we slide the scales of justice
which isn't really justice when you
slide them and you make excuses for
certain things that you do so you can
look at the good you do and say oh well
I've done these good things I want to
turn a blind eye to these bad things
that I do occasionally you know yeah
without giving away too much of the
story as as Trevor was saying these
character arcs you can also see what
seems good it's interesting look at
perception what's this absolutely that
but and and you know looking deeper at
someone's intentions you know so which
is something were exposed to every day
on Twitter these days not getting to
we're not going too far into it but yeah
so how often would you say you're handed
an acting role like it offers yeah where
someone's just like this is a role we
know we want you to play versus you have
to go in you have to audition you have
to play the game or just you know come
back and someone says we know we want
well not every offer you don't want to
do every offer that you get yeah so how
often it's kind of cyclical it kind of
depends what's out what's popular I've
got so much work now behind me there's
no tallying really
who's seen what you know so I mean it
goes in waves you know I think in the
last few years this is certainly one of
them but when I read the script I was
like oh my god I really want to play
this role like this would be amazing so
you guys we found each other you know
anything and I loved working with Trevor
and rich of course and it was just great
the collaboration was really fantastic
it was a good time and these kind of
Indians especially you know they were
open to suggestions and ideas and based
off some of the research that I had done
so but to answer your question no I I I
probably get a offer a couple offers a
month so is that what determines it for
you cuz I felt with Nathan you really
owned this person then you you inhabited
this person's skin
is that why you might turn something
down is that you feel like I don't know
if I can own it I don't know if I can
respect it or that's not well I need f
initely appreciate a challenge a
challenge as an artist and you I'd like
to be challenged I can't be challenged
and do things that I haven't done before
so that's when I get to learn a new
skill set when I get to jump into
another culture another life style
you know there's only a handful of roles
that I really won't play like pedophiles
one they called me about the lovely
bones and I was like I heard about this
boy this is amazing but what I
understand and yeah you gotta meet with
you to posit play this role I'm like
it's about a pedophile it's not really
about a pedophile I'm like right it's
about a little girl and you guys a
pedophile well you don't really seem
team pedophile things it doesn't matter
I don't want to be the image of someone
who says wow that's what I do or that's
how I feel or you know I don't
I just can't I can't I can't the
research on that is taxing on the soul I
don't I don't
I'm very anti bat you know so it's uh so
I passed on it I passed on it I said hey
let's stay like two cheek get it and get
a nomination that was before he was a
name wasn't even in the mix I thought
mistaken I think Stan Lee did do it and
get a nomination I don't know I'd be
ashamed personally but that's just me
sir you know if you were to give someone
a five-minute acting lesson what would
be like a couple things like a
five-minute acting lesson um gosh I
guess it depends on the material you
know he can't teach everything you know
and you know especially the stuff that
you've learned in 30 years so I'd rather
give you what you need you for this
audition then you know things that
you'll just carry throughout your career
I mean hopefully those little lessons
will be some kind of creative anchor for
you to keep in your back pocket which is
always sweet I've ran into quite a few
older older older than when I worked
with them kids that uh reached out to me
recently and thank them for the acting
lessons that I'd taught them and the
mentorship and stuff so so we know that
being on set is not just acting it's
navigating personalities and politics
and hierarchies how do you earn the
respect of a fellow actor do the work do
the work do the work I and it's funny
because you go into certain projects you
know with an Ed Harris like on Westworld
and then on this film as well but I
already won Ed's respect in this film
and in Westford I had not so you know I
called a few friends that had worked
with him to find out a little background
on them and then um I just studied
really hard
I studied really hard to learn my lines
I studied hard to learn his lines just
in case he was like What's My Line why I
had to be able to like I see I think you
say but uh maybe this is I don't know
you never know how they're gonna take it
like he's gonna navigate so I'm
navigating and um then he goes oh thanks
partner
alright so I did that and then I slammed
the scene where my daughter my wife gets
killed and then he came running over to
me and just pointing at me and
builtin and for all things like yes yes
yes and he kicks me on my shin
like real hard and he goes that's how
you do it and then he when he walked
away I was like I hope that's gonna
leave a mark good at Harris did that
makes a good a good job it's pretty rad
it was pretty awesome so that's why I
got his respect but I'm sure there's
different yeah it's like you said you
got to navigate a navigate Sam Jackson I
was dying to get his respect probably
you know I mean he's definitely a great
mentor you know only second of my
grandfather you know but this man knows
everybody's lines you knows everybody's
lies he knows what the camera wound what
line and where he did what and he knows
everything
it's really amazing so I am in
rehearsals mmm rehearsals Samuel I know
he was teaching me less we've had this
conversation before so he's got these
giant monologues at the end of the film
that are actually much bigger than what
even ended up in the film and the
rehearsals he Kevin Reynolds like hey
you ready you guys ready to do this
scene yeah man let's let's do it and sim
looks up he's like yeah man he throws
his scenes on the floor
he doesn't eat them he's got the big
speeches anyway so I'm I've holding my
gun and then he just like looks up if
you got tears he can control this I on
this side too by the way he can make
this cry right now you can make this cry
he can hold them I can't do that but he
can so when I saw him holding the tears
and he literally just put the pedal to
the metal and I thought oh my god I I
don't know if I can ever be that good
sigh I just remember uh just racing home
racing home and just delving as deeply
as I could just to get any ounce of
respect from him yeah he's a tough love
kind of guy so you got really really
really earned it yeah sometimes those
people are easier to trust you know
especially in industry where you know
you know you wanted a professional but
sometimes tough love people are actually
easier to to trust cuz you kind of know
where they're coming from mmm yeah I
mean I talked to him quite often nice
yeah
I honestly didn't really know I think
this came I lost my father to a suicide
two days I was at my father's funeral
two days before the climax of the movie
and we shot the movie in sequence so I
was really emotional
rather suicidal type of a scenario and
we done the rehearsal and they'd already
asked me if they minded if I would mind
doing my coverage first instead of
Samuel it's first because I was
obviously dealing with some heavy life
issues they all supported me
tremendously and it was I think it was
then that I actually had the courage to
even ask what's what same thing about
the work I'm doing anyway
like sure we can do coverage on me I'm
fine with that
as Sam code says it was Sam once because
I'll do it her Sam wants and they were
like yeah he's totally fine with it and
that's when I asked them cuz Samuel
himself didn't tell me he was holding it
close to the chest
is really dope good ma hello them so
it's interesting because when sometimes
you're at a point where it's like
certain things are going on and if
everything falls apart it's okay
I you know we were having this
conversation driving over here as long
as you you know and I'm stealing your
words by the way I'm sorry
you were saying something about staying
true to yourself so I think sometimes in
those moments some amazing things can
happen because you're at this point
where you're not really about pleasing
somebody you're just kind of like doing
what's right in the moment and sometimes
really amazing things can happen it
started way to live I've been learning
you know I think we can as true as we
think we're being to ourselves we can
always be a little truer you know
seeking a depth of authenticity if you
will you don't like like I just I've
just on this crazy journey lately
through through my work and the demands
of trying to do better work this pushed
me to to lose sleep and study harder and
faster and just go longer and it's um
it's just interesting because if you pay
attention to the signs in those moments
and do what's right you know what speaks
to your integrity
I can always rest well with whatever
happens you know I'm not feeling bad I'm
feeling good about the decisions I make
not a good feeling
what movie made you want to be an actor
I can't really say a movie it was
actually a series of you know it's like
you go to college and it's like right
away they're like oh you got to select
what you're gonna do for the rest of
your life and like at 18 like I can't
even buy alcohol yeah we're gonna make a
life decision I can't even you know II
mean it's like so it was just such a
weird thing and what's with college prep
high school so you know all these guys
were gonna high v League colleges
afterwards and things like that and
I figured out towards you in high school
that I didn't want to do that I wanted
to be an actor and Entering during this
moment of like wondering you know is
lost Mele should I do it shouldn't I do
it I had a series of I was teaching
martial arts at the time to children and
I had a moment where I just had a series
of adults and children all asked me if I
was an actor for vows I reminded them of
this actor or this character all within
like seems like a six six to eight week
span I'd have people with me and be
happening it was happening like just so
frequently it was just really like all
right maybe I should listen to the
voices so these people that I don't know
and becoming either and I asked my
grandfather my mom wasn't into it
it's just no way now you're not gonna
make it when she laughed at me which
sucks as a kid you need to turn to your
parents as mentors and teachers and
missing out but that's a whole nother
story grandpa said yes so I'm grateful
for that when he said you can do it
that's all I needed to hear is from
somebody I cared about that I knew cared
about me telling me something like that
you know in casino throughout your
career you're like you give hundreds of
thousands of doubts even while working
you know I spoke to Jack Lemmon on a
film that I was doing that he was doing
an app and he working with him really
hard enough and then um and I asked him
I said I asked him about the you know I
mean he's a legend I knew that then when
I was in my 20s working with him and I
asked him about how he dealt with the
challenges back in his day you know
grandpa was a contractor so he had work
every week whether he worked or not he
was getting paid and he was like oh my
god it's close I thought every gig was
my last gig you know that's Jack Lemmon
like you thought every gift so I'm okay
I'm okay when I get really scared or I
think I'm not gonna make it or I got my
bills paid for the most part you know
I'm good
you know I live in a mansion but I don't
want a mansion
I don't need a mansion you know to be
happy problems the prosperity
yeah what do you want people to take
from your character Nathan I don't know
people be more open-minded to things you
know questioning things be moved by the
film in some way shape or form it makes
them a better person hopefully but it's
definitely entertaining though so it is
just be entertained how's that I think
everything else will follow
yeah it's a fun one
yeah and there's an interesting ending I
don't want a whole bunch I spent so many
moments in that film so interesting it's
it's it's a fun one I'm happy with this
fun I'm really really happy I'm a tough
critic especially on my own stuff I'd be
the first to tell you to not see and
then put it that way
okay I've had friends okay hey we're
gonna support you like no you know you
go cuz you want to see the movie you
don't go to support me cuz I don't want
to take the blame for this one
you know and this one I bring it yeah
there won't be any blame this one's a
good one excellent yeah